sure as all the other players might
happen in the tournament yeah
and uh pressure is on for pregnant
online this one black pieces he's down
by one point here we go here we go and
it's the english opening so ding not
opening with his favorite queen's pawn
uh we see the four nights variation now
of the english and
okay a set of trades in the middle of
the board black's knight going back
white's now gonna castle his king this
is known as the reverse dragon variation
because white's formation if you look at
the white king the white bishop in front
of it and that's a formation you
normally see in the dragon sicilian here
it's basically the same opening just
colors reversed
and uh okay ding chooses to develop both
of his bishops on the longest possible
diagonals fiance his bishops good
opening choice do you think here ivanka
yeah i think it's a great opening choice
and he's been quite successful in this
tournament using the english variation
and uh of course it's a
like a reverse sicilian with a tempo up
and uh the big plan is just simply to
get those rook on the open line and uh
start utilizing the c5 square
yeah so uh we'll see this happen at some
point in the near future but prague
first needs to decide how to develop his
pieces same as the last game in a way
both sides just need to bring their
pieces to good squares connect the rooks
uh start taking control
and uh okay ding slightly shook his head
i'm slightly surprised there
because it's just a normal position why
shake your head in the opening maybe
just surprised by this opening variation
and yeah i've seen him win actually
several games in this type of structure
i'm not sure this exact position but at
least this type of structure doing
lowran
meanwhile prague maybe slightly less
experience here than his opponent okay
yeah the sicilian is really uh like one
of the most well uh is one of the most
um normal openings to play with black
but why do we see the english so seldom
as white yeah which is like the same but
just opposite color you're right there
i've always asked myself that question
so um the just to show this point as
well um the sicilian is after one e4
black meets it by pushing his sea pawn
two squares forward and we've seen that
the tour actually it scored very well
for blacks some of these sicilians um
but yeah why not play the same opening
just with one extra move so white does
the same we're pushing the sea pawn
forward and as we saw prague do
basically after this central pawn white
has the sicilian with colours reversed
just one extra move um so you're right
heidi i mean as we've seen on the on the
tour though this season the english has
become extremely popular maybe it's just
the trend in the last year or two but in
the past
very rare you see the english opening at
the top level normally it's always one
e4 or one d4 and uh if we fast forward
to the current position i think it's
because in the sicilian uh the reason
it's popular now in the sicilian often
the
opponent's king here the black king
would actually castle on the other side
of the board and we'd see kind of both
sides kind of
both kings on opposite flanks lots of
attacks throwing pawns forward here
because black has one less uh move
black's king has to go on the short side
so we have same side castling as we call
it so it's more positional strategic
play
i guess yeah maybe just players in the
past they were impatient they wanted to
go direct pushing one of these pawns
forward in the beginning of the game now
players because the level of everyone is
so good sometimes you have to be patient
you have to be happy to maneuver and
take things slow and i love openings
where you kind of keep your two pawns
central pawns nice and flexible
personally
and interesting point and
whilst the players are thinking about
what decisions they're going to take
well i just wanted to
say we have two competitions going on we
have the selfie challenge and we have
our quiz of the day
and uh i'll start off with our selfie
challenge because we you guys have been
awesome and sending us loads and loads
of pictures and moki says
move i am watching the game
that's good
and nice yes very very nice and uh okay
the light squared bishop
develops itself
yeah can i show quickly one selfie from
johnson and it says here's a nice selfie
thanks for the night off sicilian just
curious is the fort knox variation a
good defense i've heard it's very solid
but who's there in the selfie aha david
it took me a while to recognize myself
there
is that outside the good night is that
or is this on the subway i remember you
met someone on the subway and took like
yeah i couldn't remind you
not to be big headed but i have been
recognized a few times so i'm not sure
which time that was i'm wearing a bag
yeah
elmer you have to let me know where that
was please
tweet us uh where did you meet david and
uh
yeah
no i mean i love getting those kind of
selfies uh especially if you managed to
stump david and in the meantime let's go
back to the games ah you can't really
remembered yeah i mean i couldn't see
the picture very large there just a
small image and it was uh
the day before may 17th
so it's on may 16th i was stocking up on
supplies for the party
we do have um a move and after you told
us about that we're gonna head down to
simon at the good night to see what's
going on yep so just a very
kind of solid stable move there white
stepping a pawn forward i think ding was
slightly afraid that pragnanda would
have pushed the black pawn in the middle
of the board down into the white camp
hitting one of the white knights so he's
just marking out his territory that's
just a very solid stable move all right
well ding is playing super fast with the
white pieces in this game let's go down
two simon at the good night i bet some
good openings are being played there
tonight as well simon
i'm not sure about good openings maybe
some drunken openings getting played
here um i'm on a really tough day's work
here ha ha ha ha but anyway you can see
there's lots of people playing it's
getting really busy here uh it's great
to see such a lovely environment where
you can just come have a beer play some
chess and we're just gonna go have a
very quick word now with the owner one
of the owners of the good night so uh
let's go and say hello to christopher uh
hello christopher how are you doing
today you doing well yeah i'm fine thank
you great and who would you like to win
this match we saw that ding won the
first game are you rooting for ding or
for the young prank
it's really hard i mean
i kind of have sympathy for prague
especially since it's like in rapid
rating in feeder he's approximately the
same rating as i am which is uh
concerning i mean so you're a super
grand master
no but he hasn't played federated uh
federated rapid games in
two or three years he has a very low
rating doesn't he and you also told me
something quite interesting we were
talking about openings today in the
studio and
you told me that one of your favorite
openings is the same as someone on the
panel and um tell us what your favorite
opening is
the bird is the word and uh yeah i was
very happy when magnus played it uh
earlier this tournament uh he hasn't
done it in five years so
that was great and i know heidi is quite
a fan of the opening as well brilliant i
actually like the bird as well but i
have to say it's a rubbish opening um so
sorry about that christopher sorry about
that heidi uh maybe we should go back to
the studio and see if heidi agrees with
my assessment of the bird
very interesting
and well heidi is it about the birds
opening or is it about birds because you
have a tv show about birds yeah i love
birds as well but i actually used to
play the birds opening before
some years ago but then i started um
training with the norwegian
grandmaster and he said that i couldn't
play it i had to play something
different because you have to learn
proper chess openings to be a good chess
player
and then when you come at magnus level
then you can start playing the bird
maybe yeah but i actually play against
christopher we're in the same in the
same club and we have agreed that if we
meet each other we're gonna play the
bird aha
very cool the bird opening we've seen it
once in the military championship magnus
played it and uh we don't have a bird in
this one we do have good chest moves yep
good chest moves and white just pushing
pawns i want to say as well with the
bird you do avoid the french defense
heidi yeah that's true
but uh meanwhile in this english opening
we do see white marking out the
territory um the reason i find these
positions so difficult to play with
white is because you always have to play
these kind of small pawn pushers ding
with this last move pushing this pawn
forward one square it's as if you've
only pushed your pawns forward one
square you're just kind of playing on
the first three ranks first three rows
but
if we think strategically in this type
of opening this actually long term is
quite good for white because if you look
in the center of the board white has two
pawns and the kind of e and d lines
black only has one and as ivanka
mentioned earlier this kind of semi-open
c file means that you can later maneuver
your knight around for example okay uh
prague they're just getting the rook's
nice and centralized black's pieces look
great by the way but if white takes a
step back and say black doesn't do too
much and then takes a step forward with
his knight this is the key square and
actually ding chooses to advance in the
current position he pushes this pawn
forward it's all about trying to get the
white knight to this square later maybe
either this root or this root
and if you can get it there often you
will make black's pieces feel very
uncomfortable it's as if you're just
kind of on the third rank then inching
forward to the fourth rank inching
forward again to the fifth ranking there
is a small threat in the position of
pushing this pawn even further forward
kicking away this black knight for
example again black is too slow then
once the black knight moves now maybe
you can grab a pawn in the center of the
board hitting the black queen so i'm
expecting um in the current position
black to either
prevent this pawn push by pushing a pawn
of his own just kind of covering the
square or black can just ignore this
pawn push and for example retreat a
bishop just to defend his central pawn
another typical idea in this line i
think we might well see it happen over
the next couple of moves is the black
knight jumping into the center in a way
white is so solid white okay the black
bishop did go back white is so solid
that in black has to create some action
black has to do something before white's
pieces come out before the white queen
comes out the white rook gets better
black's pieces are pretty much perfectly
placed so jumping into the center with
the knight makes a lot of sense and if
we see a trade black is very happy in
these types of positions because
suddenly
black's rook gains an open line
i mean it's very balanced at the moment
both sides have chances but far far from
a boring position it's full of potential
yeah i totally agree with that
assessment there
it's uh brewing up to be a real dog
fight and uh
well once the players are thinking then
uh well we also have a quiz of the day
yeah we're asking what is positions
opening nightmare
and uh how many of these are familiar to
you both and uh hongware ralto says uh
fighting against the gela system in the
pack which is a aggressive system is
worse than watching the movie cats oh
i don't think i've actually ever seen it
but the songs from the musical very good
i like them um john hickman says that
their opening right nightmare is when
they're preparing and they see that
their opponent plays the same openings
and they know all their tricks
has that one ever happened that actually
happened to me when i was preparing
against david i was like oh my goodness
i've actually sent him analysis as well
i was like he won't use it i'm pretty
sure he won't use it but will he play
that opening and then we'll be like oh
yeah i mean when i was young i think
that's the thing that inspired me to
broaden my repertoire to learn new
openings because i used to play the same
thing every single time and occasionally
i would meet someone who knows exactly
the same openings exactly the same
tricks that i do so i decided you know
if you can't
if you can't beat them you know you
might as well expand your opening
repertoire and i think that's why i kind
of
decided
yeah it's uh i need to know more that
was quite good about playing the bird
because whenever people were preparing
against me they would be like okay she
either plays f4 which is bird or e4 and
and they would be like i know a lot of
things uh against e4 i'd just prepare
against f4 but i didn't normally play f4
anymore i normally played d4 are you
switched
yeah yeah
right
that is a cool thing about chess
tournaments chess games it starts long
before the first move right with all the
opening prep it's such a long
lasting sport yeah definitely i mean
having the first move is like having the
serve and i i do remember when i was
preparing for fabiano caruana
in a big tournament i was round one so
the weaker players play the top players
and i looked at his repertoire and i was
like
he plays
everything what can i do to prepare
against this and so um i just had a look
at his previous uh games and he'd been
playing the king's porn opening he'd
just been pushing his king pawn and i
was like okay he's going to do that so i
prepared all morning on my trusted kara
khan
and
i turn up guess what he plays he plays
exactly the first move that we saw ding
play against the pregnant the queen's
pawn and i was i felt like going to him
well there you go i might as well put
all my preparation to one side and we'll
freestyle it but obviously you can't say
that to your opponent
yeah and uh for example recently i
played a match against nils grandelias
and we know each other very very well i
spent months and months playing online
games and openings i would never play
against him in the match
just so that he would prepare the wrong
openings and i think i i mean i must
have entered dozens of tournaments which
i knew would end up on the database
where i only played
really aggressive lines and then against
him i played the quietest most boring
lines ever so
yeah it's just misdirection uh and was
he pushed in the wrong direction did you
talk to him about it afterwards that
should he see by his play in my white
games yes but he correctly predicted my
bluff when i had black oh no
it was pretty obvious i think that i was
bluffing with my black openings i would
never dare to play aggressively uh as
black so but with whites when i had
white at least he was surprised every
time wow but that is very interesting
when we see this match writing playing
candidates in two three weeks is he
bluffing with his openings here
um it's very interesting i think the
english opening it's on lots of people's
radar nowadays and the english is so
flexible that he's going to potentially
save it up for the candidates but
something that magnus carson said as
well if ding
doesn't play any of his normal openings
if he only plays other stuff people will
know he's bluffing people know he's just
trying to send them in the wrong
direction sometimes you have to mix it
up sometimes you play what you want to
do sometimes you throw in a few rare
things and then you kind of keep them uh
you make them unsure you don't want to
just focus in one direction because then
it's obvious that you're not going to do
that you're going um
yeah so i think he's playing some of his
normal openings some surprises he's
trying to mix uh mixed things but i was
going to say something about doing he
hasn't had that much time to prepare for
the candidates because first he had to
play this
marathon month
and uh then it was unclear whether he
would actually get to the thing and it
is it's finally clear now he's got his
visa um i actually don't know he is
booking his tickets and getting his visa
that is what ding is saying he is
invited by peter his he is qualified he
is ready
um and i don't think covet restrictions
is in the way for him this time so it
should work out okay but karjakin has
appealed hasn't it isn't that he can't
he if his appeal is approved then
karjakin has to complace but i think it
was
um
it's appeal to fidei was rejected but i
think he can appeal to the
to the courts yeah in switzerland and
switzerland the courts of sports of
arbitration oh it's so french is it yeah
um either way i mean it's unlikely that
that decision would go through in time i
mean the candidate starts in three weeks
now yeah so um
yeah it does look like it will be doing
the drama of the candidates and he is a
well-deserved participant in the
candidates he didn't get to play any of
the qualification tournaments did he
no grand prix
grand prix grand swiss world cup nothing
um i think since the previous candidates
until this last month he pretty much
played nothing only a handful of games
so uh yeah i guess in one sense you
could argue that drew he had the whole
pandemic to prepare his openings yeah to
study chess to study his openings but
yeah until last month at least he was
very rusty i think he's more than made
up for that now
definitely and we can kind of say the
candidates already started we are taking
a look at openings ding is one of the
players and a bunch of moves bunch of
moves and a really interesting decision
quite a rare decision from ding loren um
if we just jump in and rewind actually
just a couple of moments here pregnant
decided to push his pawn forward really
trying to make uh ding kind of force him
into a decision that he doesn't want to
take yet and this pawn is under threat
now from the black pawn and usually as
soon as uh kind of a wing pawn
challenges you you don't want to catch
it away from the center you don't want
to ruin your pawn chain and normally
bypass this by pushing your own pawn
forward also you kick away this black
knight from its nice post but as
mentioned this would allow the black
knight to jump in gaining a bit of time
in the process and now if you don't take
this black knight off the board then
this white pawn is actually a bit weak
um therefore ding decided okay i'm going
to ruin my own pawn structure i'm
actually going to capture here and white
now has an isolated pawn
in an end game this is going to be weak
but on the bright side black's knight is
temporarily on the edge of the board so
it's kind of pros and cons you've lost
the integrity of your pawn structure but
you've worsened your opponent's pieces
and uh now ding retreating with the
white knight this has been met by
pragnanda nice safe move i love this
type of move in rapid chess especially
because now you you know you'll never
get checkmated on the back rank your
king has some breathing space uh maybe
the one the light squad bishop can hide
back here as well
if necessary
what do you what do you think here
ivanka heidi about the placement of the
knights i mean it looks a bit weird
these two black knights but
you can't kick them away they can draw
some squares you can't control this i
agree with that and one thing that is
slightly
worrying
i feel for for ding is that
you know that uh pawn on a3 it's kind of
weak it's by itself it's got no friends
and my experience when i
was playing
this
against the sicilianist i always lost on
that side of the board on the left you
know i always made a mistake there and
you know something happened and whatever
i generated in the middle
it wasn't enough
yeah it's hard for white it's hard for
ding to generate anything in the middle
because black is just really well
centralized if white ever pushes a pawn
in the center of the board it's only
going to backfire
so ding is a bit stuck
i mean i would be looking at moves such
as the one you mentioned earlier ivanka
just jumping in with the knight maybe to
this square for example if black just
waits um
say he drops his bishop back this knight
jump would at least persuade black to
part with a bishop for the night and
suddenly white's pieces really come to
life hitting the knight now
this bishop has opened up this would
look good but i guess black does have
one move and
i mean maybe black can stop this i'm not
really sure how maybe the black queen
would get active hitting this bishop
maybe this is the one downside to the
white knight moving away
okay
when in doubt that's the motto nowadays
push harry the h pawn it literally does
nothing but it's a nice move and again
maybe giving the white king some
breathing space later
maybe you're gonna clamp down push your
pawn further forward gain some space
it's just mysterious wow well is it
sensible when you look at the clock's
time ding had been playing really fast
and then he was about to take down to
pragnanda's clock as well to just keep
his time advantage and think on prague's
time now yeah i think it's good that he
made a decision i'm not sure it's the
best decision i think maybe he had to be
a bit more direct and improve the white
pieces but
yeah i mean in rapid chess i think this
is a decent move a decent
uh choice and also it's going to confuse
prague you can see on prague's face a
minute ago
what's the idea behind that one
baffled as well i don't get it but the
evaluation is
one pawn up to prague yeah it's
surprising it's that far i guess maybe
it's because white's porn that uh ivanka
highlighted is so weak that
eventually it might drop off the board
also black's pieces they do look much
more active than white's pieces
again i don't think there's anything
direct or winning here for black but
plus one for black plus one for pregnant
that's a positive sign
this is the type of advantage though
that could disappear in the space of one
move it's not kind of an eternal plus
one for black
it's not a long term plus one it's kind
of for the next few moves maybe
black is on top
well he has to make a comeback prague he
did lose the first game three rapid
games left in the match this is one of
them he has to win either this one or
one of the two final games to
tie the match i don't think prague has
ever been in a situation where he's had
to make a comeback
maybe not i mean i was thinking to the
oslo esports
she won everything in three
and he lost everything in three yeah
it was a nice little pattern that he had
going on there
and uh yesterday of course he took the
early lead against aneesh giri
so
i guess in the oslo esports cup when he
lost those matches in three he was
always down after two games almost in
the muslin situation not quite must win
but
um yeah i guess any situation match
situation he's definitely gonna have
less experience than being here he just
has to compensate for that with energy
and
um kind of the trickiness that he showed
throughout the tour and meanwhile black
has made one move he's brought his rook
back to its starting square so
decentralizing the black rook but the
whole idea is that that white pawn on
the a3 square the lone ranger
is a target in a way it makes sense yeah
but i think what you're talking about
like the mental game here when you're
when you're down because he's so young
he hasn't played well he's played loads
of games but he hasn't been in
in all these situations as much as the
older players and
and i think magnus for example is really
really good at the mental game and sort
of coming back after he's uh he's lost
something but
uh pregnant we also saw that last time
in oslo um esport cup that he maybe
because the pressure was so high when he
was leading into the last uh last day
that he's maybe he has to work more on
his
mental game to
come back that's true but uh one thing i
did notice with pragnando when we had
our chess talks was that um
he was pretty chill you know
you know he he told me that when he got
his grandma's title he didn't celebrate
that much he just you know smiled
when he beat his first yeah he just
enjoyed you know he just like oh yeah
you know on to the next on to the next
yeah and i remember when he beat magnus
for the first time as well because he
came on the show and he goes
yeah you know but it wasn't my favorite
game
i i prefer my game against level neroni
and check that out yeah
when he beat me when he was 12 i
remember him shaking his head i was like
wait you just beat me why are you
shaking her
but yeah maybe it's just yeah he's
always looking for the next challenge
he's not he's not satisfied sign of a
champion maybe true sign of a champion
yeah
i have to say you know my experience
with frank is only interviewing him and
it's just the biggest difference in
those three months since he beat magnus
carlsen in a game and all the interviews
we've done with him in tournaments
leading up to this he just seems five
years older in the way he's answering
he's so much more comfortable
smile on his face relaxing it's
remarkable yeah well he has had a lot of
practice because i do remember that he
told me that uh when he defeated magnus
the phone did not stop ringing for a
week and they had to come to some
negotiation they said you know hey we
will answer your interviews but you've
got to stop doing this while i'm playing
chess yeah yeah have you ever had that
david uh when you didn't know with all
your world records
when i was young there was a lot when i
beat grandmaster when i was eight years
old i know my parents they said they had
to kind of send people away they had to
um i mean there were too many requests
to go on shows and things but
i mean i was oblivious i was eight years
old
i was busy playing with my toys in my
back garden or kicking a football around
i had no idea but i think it was only
later when i realized it must have been
intense for my family and must have been
intense i think i wouldn't have dealt
with it that well in my teens there was
less much less than uh
pregnant but there were a few moments
when
there was some interest and i think i
just wanted to hide away i just wanted
to focus on the chest and i found it
hard but prague's taking it in a stride
and
he doesn't seem flustered distracted at
all i mean look at the camera he's just
so focused on the board eyes just
darting around calculating
it doesn't get to him yeah i know there
is a story with with magnus as well when
he started becoming an international
name 60 minutes called his dad and said
like yeah we decided we're going to do a
story on magnus carlsen and as i was
like okay we're having dinner might call
you back later
maybe maybe we'll do 60 minutes maybe
not
so mike has never been too interested in
the media stuff but i guess again sign
of a true champion right they just uh
it's all about the chess and the sport
i'm sorry it must be harder now though
for the younger players when there's so
much social media it's kind of harder to
hide away uh i don't know how old you uh
are but i'm i'm guessing when you were
eight there wasn't that much like
it's easy to sort of protect the
children yeah that's a good point it's
east it's harder now to to hide away
from it all and we know pragnanda he's
on twitter you know prime minister is
tweeting about him the biggest
superstars in india tweeting about him
obviously they notice it yeah
i mean all you need to do is log on to a
computer you i think probably gets his
names popping up all over the place yeah
it's hard to ignore it's hard to
minimize that kind of close the apps
focus on studying chess studying
openings
that's what he has to do yeah i think
when it comes to pragnanda he's
surrounded by a team you know so he does
have someone on the social media side so
he to some extent he is protected from
that but
it still is pretty intense
um especially these days you know
because you make it you make a wrong
decision somewhere here there and
everywhere and suddenly you know
everyone has an opinion everyone wants
to have their say
and uh yeah
i think that's quite tough and as david
says especially if you're a teenager and
you do you want to do and this is one
when i spoke to pragananda all he wants
to do
is chess yeah and i loved what he said
to me about the exams he goes yeah i
just have to do some exams
just get them over with and uh i i love
the fact that you know he's playing
great chess against sting and he's
putting ding under immense pressure in
this particular position and
just think about it he just did that
exam in the morning it's incredible and
thinking for almost three minutes he
finally makes his move david yeah i
think it's a good move that light
squared bishop wasn't doing too much on
its previous diagonal it was just kind
of staring down at some well protected
white pawns so now this
black bishop is pointing towards this
queen side towards the left flank and
it's controlling a lot of squares my one
concern is it did cost him a lot of time
he's under four minutes again and as we
saw in the last game
okay ding was great in the last game but
prague did slightly fall apart when he
was low on the clock and yeah in
previous events up until the last couple
of months time trouble was by far his
biggest weakness prague
and uh he's handled it well this
tournament so far but this is the type
of position with all the heavy pieces
all the minor pieces still on the board
things could go wrong if you panic in
time pressure this is not the type of
position either side can really control
um meanwhile ding is stuck on the first
three ranks for white white's just
maneuvering the queen slides across one
square again very mysterious not exactly
clear where that queen is going i think
he just wants to
keep her on a nice safe square maybe the
white queen is tied down actually
defending that weak white pawn on the a
line
and now prague re-centralizes relocates
his knight this just looks beautiful for
black actually really nice harmony with
the black pieces yeah i i loved what
he's doing you know he's saying hey the
night's not useful anymore on the edge
nights on the rim are dim and he's maybe
going to really really root it to the
center
and uh one of the ideas that david's
highlighted and just all the time posing
questions to ding and i just look at the
piece oh look at this all the pieces are
huddling together i don't understand
this move
i mean is he trying to break out i
mean i get it i mean they're nice and
cozy this little family just bunched up
in a ball it's as if they're
i mean how many pieces this is if
there's six people living in a one
bedroom flat uh right now these pieces
but
yeah i mean it's so easy for black to
improve his pieces too i mean for
example the black rook can come up the
board i'm not sure exactly where uh
maybe this square and then the other
rook could slide across just trying to
target this weak pawn and that looks
like one plan for example ivanka also
mentioned the black knight jumping in at
some point you can jump into the center
but you do have to work out whether
white can grab this pawn so maybe you
could just defend this pawn first with a
rook for example and then jump in with
your knight at some point
it feels like black can improve this
knight can jump to the center this
knight can jump to the center and uh
yeah i just i'm somehow just attracted
to going after white's biggest weakness
this pawn and that means maybe just
doubling up the rooks on the a file
so this just a very simple idea but just
i'm trying to get inside prag's head as
well and he just loves these kind of
moves where he improves the
kind of dynamism the potential of his
pieces if you think about it black's
pieces they're all kind of doing
something they're all actually on great
squares maybe apart from this rook which
is centralized but staring at its own
pieces so
improving that might be the first step
yeah white pieces though they don't make
a great impression especially this rook
what's it doing there
yeah i must admit i didn't anticipate
when we kind of looked at the opening
that this would be
the result to me a little bit of an
opening nightmare
yeah
didn't quite work well and uh well
pragnanda going for your plan there just
choosing a different role for the rooks
to line up on yeah actually i like this
one more um the black rook does have
potential it covers the whole fifth rank
it can't be attacked right now that
black rook um in a good way the white
pieces can't go over and kind of kick it
and uh yeah again it's just every move
is costing prague one to two minutes oh
i said that rook can't be kicked away
but we did see the white knight jump
forward and a trade and
suddenly occasionally
gets up i was like did he just resign
never see them leave the board but he's
really happy i think with the change in
uh pace the changing developments in
this game and maybe we can just quickly
show what happened there because it was
a quick flurry of moves and meanwhile
the moves keep coming thick and fast
if we rewind the white knight jumped
forward attacking this black rook on the
edge of the board and uh okay black
decided let's get rid of this knight
it's too strong a trade of knights now
we finally discover why those kind of
family of pieces were huddling up this
rook suddenly opens up and attacks the
black queen so prague may be missing uh
that he had to kind of take a time out
step his queen away and the white knight
now looking fantastic in the center of
the board white's pawns are still ugly
both of them isolated and targets
long-term but temporarily even after
prague's move lining up his rook against
this pawn white has one good piece and
that's a good start for ding but he's
away from the board prague i don't know
if he's got the camera up maybe he saw
ding leave the board and now ding's lost
nearly a minute on the clock that could
be really valuable
uh especially as we're about to enter a
time scramble wow okay he's back yeah
and he would have had the arbiter's
permission to leave yeah for sure he you
can't just
dash off somewhere and then come back
and uh yeah definitely nothing
suspicious going on there no bathroom
visit maybe yeah
they are allowed to do that but uh that
did cost him a minute
i mean a minute that's a quarter of his
time pretty much before this move and
that's going to be really valuable it's
still full of life this position i was
going to say things are just heating up
you know
because uh we have a big battle going on
because white's pieces are very active
suddenly meanwhile black will be having
all the long-term play and they will be
he'll be targeting those two weak pawns
on the left wow
look he looks very calm the bar is
roughly to the middle do you think heidi
that ding is is feeling that he is in
trouble looking at this
um
i'm not sure i'm just
well
i i'm just surprised that he he keeps on
thinking even longer now that he's lost
uh lost so much time just leaving the
board and i i mean there's not that much
time left of the game so
i really do not understand why he why he
got off the left yeah do you do you read
your opponent's body language uh heidi
normally when you play against them and
if so i mean what would you say about
the players here um i think uh pregnant
looks like he's fierce he's sort of he's
look it's like he's looking for
something yeah and ding looks
maybe a little bit more worried but i'm
not sure because i thought he looked a
bit more worried in the first game as
well but then they won
so uh because i actually played poker as
well and so and one of the things that i
love about poker is trying to read what
the languages but i must admit that ding
is a bit difficult for me to read
yeah ding always does look worried from
my experience of playing him and then
he'll unleash a winning move yeah
so okay meanwhile the black knight has
gone to the edge of the board if you
look at the black knight on the edge and
the black rook they're
i think they're just ganging up on on a
pawn and pregnant does go one pawn up
black rook now defended by its knight
white's queen under fire as well
ding has to move his queen where does he
move it to white's compensation for the
pawn he's just lost lies in the fact his
pieces are so active suddenly if you
look at the white rooks they were
terrible just four or five moves ago the
white rooks have opened up the white
knight in the middle of the board also
the white bishops on decent diagonals so
uh one point down but not the end of the
world here for ding i think he's chosen
a good kind of way to dynamically
sacrifice a pawn sometimes you've got to
do that if you have weaknesses
let them go don't go passive defending
them let those pawns drop but get active
pieces in return yeah look at ding he is
ticking down on the clock
moving his queen yeah centralizes his
queen great square uh ivanka calls this
the goldilocks square yeah it's uh the
third row it means the queen can just go
to the right go to the left she has the
ability to travel across the board and
things are going wild and so this is the
perfect perfect final to watch and i
just wanted to say a big shout out to
batsy chess club who have entered our
selfie competition to say look what
we're watching
and get this battery chess club is
holding the world's first virtual club
chess club meeting a watch party for the
chessable masters final
and so simon
you might recognize someone in our space
grab a beer and let's settle down to
watch and uh these two
pragnanda and ding are providing the
fireworks
and well that's actually very
interesting first virtual chess club
meeting and
i i hear rumors you're you're known to
this battersea chess club david i am
i've been there a few times i've played
some games there played a symbol played
a tournament yeah shout out to aldo leon
everyone yeah that's easy but now they
made a virtual chess club how cool yeah
i mean they do some great work they're
really innovative with their events um
supporting women's chess supporting all
sorts of uh chess in the community so
yeah great work i don't know we need
more chess clubs just like that yeah we
need more virtual meetups right
definitely that's been an idea that i've
had for a long time you know like a
match like this just have everyone kind
of getting together talking
sharing their thoughts yeah and okay
meanwhile we've seen the dark square
bishops leave the board
and uh big threat in the air
for pragmata to deal with
five seconds
on the players but huge threat pragnanda
has to deal with this check
this check if he'd been careless here
would have allowed a nasty fork on the
queen but also the king the knight
protected by her queen so
this would have been winning for
dinglaren prague defended it by bringing
his knight back in this position the
black knight now covering this key
square but suddenly it feels like
everything's a bit loose for black this
black queen is placed on a bad square
this black rook suddenly is loose
doesn't have any protectors it's not
quite trapped at first i thought oh
maybe you could step back with the
knight and trap this rook but there's
only one safe square it is enough
however the rook can centralize itself
it's just very tense white is a pawn
down as we mentioned but look at every
white piece this white queen better than
the black queen it's got great vision
down this diagonal the two white rooks
probably better than the uh the black
rooks right now and okay this rook is
almost trapped prague has to be really
careful now the bishop might come back
and try to trap it prague though reacts
by pushing his central pawn
firstly blocking this bishop and also
creating a square for the black knight i
like this last move by prague i must say
a multi-purpose move this night the
black knight if it gets there later it
will be on a dream square
yeah it has a dream square
but uh yeah the
heat is on isn't it what do you think
what will be the result in this game
it's wild kyle this is so crazy because
you know davis pointed out some amazing
plans for pregnant under but uh yeah
ding is uh potentially going to be
attacking the white rook
will it escape it's only got one hidey
hole there we go the black rook under
fire now from that bishop
yeah see if i can mention it doesn't
have too many safe squares
actually i'm trying to find a way to
trap it now the black rook the only safe
square i can see is it for to come down
two squares there we go to the second
rank if the white queen attacks it then
maybe it can go back up the board
that black rook is playing with fire
it's living a charmed life right now
it's all a bit loose though for both
sides that white knight in the central
board suddenly not as safe as it
previously was this is a three result
game anything's definitely possible and
it's gonna be about i mean it feels like
a blunders incoming from one side it's
just gonna be about who can hold their
nerves now they're both around the one
minute mark
um prague you know he's got that energy
going the youthful energy that we see
just getting the
adrenaline pumping i'm getting nervous
david i don't know about you because
it's such a crazily complicated position
it's going to be so dramatic for prague
if he blunders in this position and if
he loses then he's going to be in must
win situation in both of the two final
games how
how does he usually do david and how
what has it been like in this tournament
when he is so low on the clock prague
has been great actually when he's been
low on the clock in this tournament
we've seen several occasions where he's
actually losing or a big disadvantage
and he's been saving the games despite
having 30 seconds on the clock so
i think that was his weakness last year
when he played prague but that's where
he's improved a lot much quicker now
much more tenacious despite the clock
times and
to be honest i would rather be in a
situation like this both players low on
the clock with one extra pawn and prague
does have that one extra pawn so even if
things go wrong for him
the margin for error for prague is
slightly higher if ding makes a mistake
however he'll be a pawn down and no
compensation um if frank makes a mistake
maybe he'll just lose the pawn back and
it will be
a drawing position meanwhile a trade of
rooks has just happened so black
survived his rook did not get trapped
and uh still one pawn down for ding but
he's pushing and alice the a pawn up the
board
i'm slightly concerned about the white
king but at the moment the white king is
defended very well by its bishop
yeah i also had a little bit of a
panic when i saw the white king all by
itself but uh it's all good but uh
definitely some pressing issues for the
youngster to solve and he's just got 20
seconds on the clock
and ding is going to be targeting those
pawns on the left yeah just like the
last game it's two against one in terms
of pawns those two black horns against
the one white pawn on the corner but you
can't really push the black pawn safely
yet
okay very logical move the evaluation
bar doesn't like it but black's rook
entering an open file i can't find any
fault with that and now okay offer of a
bishop trade that black bishop was
actually creating some checkmating nets
around the white king the white king had
no breathing space while that black
bishop sits on the board so trading it
off looks decent but
now i just have a feeling it's going to
be hard for ding to win this game
feels like prague is the only one who
can win and he does indeed push one of
his pawns
one thing that you've got to be really
careful of doing in the current position
ding with one minute now just to show
this because it's one of the most common
checkmating patterns out there in chess
after a trade of bishops now this pawn
creates another mating net and the black
queen is actually ready to pounce in
and to this g2 square to checkmate the
white king so you've got to be really
careful i don't think
ding is going to rush with this exchange
if you capture
sorry if you capture this bishop if you
take it off the board you have to stop
the queen coming in for example with
your king on the side of the board but
uh yeah you definitely don't want to
allow
this pawn to sit on this square so okay
instead of trading bishops he just
shuffles his rook across these are the
targets
maybe prague has to go defensive for one
move
no he doesn't go defensive he brings
this rook up the board and i guess his
idea is that if the white queen takes
this pawn then after a trade we would
just see black stay a pawn up in the end
game it's not clear whether black sex
report is gonna decide this one for a
win but
he's gonna try
risk-free position and we've gone for
this exact line so black has one extra
pawn it's just about whether he can push
this for victory
feels very close between a win and a
draw somewhere now for prank no more
risk for the indian and uh ding dong
great things there putting his rook
behind the past pawns rooks always built
belong behind passports yeah
so
logical play from both sides i like the
fact prague has taken all the risk out
of the position but
maybe fewer winning chances here than
there were when queens were still on the
board
less risk but also less reward
potentially okay he has to put his own
rook on a passive square now protecting
his own pawn
it's just this tension between the
bishops do you trade or do not and if
you do when
because the white king is kind of caught
in a box in the corner even if you trade
bishops off how is that white king ever
going to get active you can imagine the
black king coming towards the center and
whoa ding pushes upon he's trying to
trick the black bishop if the black
bishop moves back and captures this pawn
that's just moved white's bishop can
actually grab black's pawn in the center
so
it does feel a bit loose there
surprising
it wasn't the move i expected was it
i did not see that one i must admit and
now okay clever from prague the black
rook now is defending the black pawn in
the center of the board so now there is
a threat of black's bishop stepping back
and taking the white pawn on the g4
square
ding okay he suddenly put his head in
his hands again
his normal
situation but he looks very very nervous
yeah heidi being a poker player an
expert in reading body languages what do
you read from these two players now
uh i i find it really difficult to read
reading but actually i think he seems a
bit more confident now than what he did
but then he put his hands up and that
would make me think like maybe not you
oh is that a sign with a hand
i think so a little bit
players always have their tells right
there yeah their ticks
their mannerisms
okay this white pawn the white g pawn is
it going to survive though if pregnant
can win this white pawn on the g5 square
and go two pawns up he's gonna win this
game it's just about whether that is
sufficient
oh okay now the black rook can go and
grab this pawn
yes one of the black pawns is gonna fall
but black's rook can now enter give a
check to the white king come down the
board
and win a second pawn it's three versus
two now in terms of pawns but can prac
not just get greedy here i i absolutely
agree give a check
to the king
give it to it horizontally okay king
steps
now take up
pawn big question do you take the pawn
or do you keep the white king kind of
caught in a box do you push maybe
black's g pawn further forward oh i mean
the white king yes you can take this
pawn now
okay the computer here stockfish does
suggest three moves and the top two
moves are not actually being greedy now
and taking this white ball next to the
black rook aha
okay pragnanda doesn't go for one of the
top three moves but he doesn't take the
pawn so he's
not being greedy he's keeping the white
king sidelined though the white king is
cut off from the action
this one is so hard to call again i
don't know whether objectively it's
winning or not or whether it might be a
draw white's rook now is coming it wants
to go behind the black f pawn and
okay temporarily at least prague is two
pawns up
ding has been able to build up his clock
before prague is still very dramatic on
the clocks but the bar keeps liking it
for prague
yeah there must be something here i must
be winning surely two pawns up in a rook
in game but uh the question is what next
the black rook is really passive now
and it's tied eternally to the defense
of the f3 pawn
and is this yeah is this going to be a
real hindrance to
black and i think it is actually because
white's rook is very active
and uh it gives a check
so in a way white is just going to check
just annoy the black king in a way white
is just going to wait with the white
rook somewhere but the black rook how
can it ever move without giving up the
pawn next to uh the white king yeah the
black rock you're right ivanka it is a
bit stuck
and if that black pawn does disappear if
it's two versus one it should still be a
draw some winning chances but
objectively
with correct play it should be a draw
so it's just about whether black can
activate his rook and keep his third
pawn
the other option that i see for black is
actually to try to advance his own pawns
and try to
make sure that the
lone
ranger there on f3 gets some company
yeah and you can do that with baby steps
here black's just going to push one of
his pawns i feel and one of the two
pawns that hasn't moved yet push it one
square two squares
one square keep those pawns nice and
safe then you bring the king down then
you push the other pawn then you push
kind of step by step caterpillar is what
i call it caterpillar yeah because the
king is so important in the end game
people say it's worth three or four
points even uh
so yeah it's uh it's important to get it
into the into the middle yeah um
especially i mean the more pieces that
disappear the more
kings uh kind of can play that role it
seems so scary though i always think it
seems so scary yeah it does but here's
here comes the key the good thing is
white will never checkmate the black
king because white only has a rook you
need at least two or three pieces to
checkmate
uh so the black king can happily wander
into the center of the board so ding is
happy with the draw now ding wood
he's on his knees begging for the draw
at the moment uh but
pragmata won't give it to him easily
it's just about whether the black king
or the black pawns can advance the black
rook at the bottom of the board and the
pawn near it they are stuck
for now um do you think another baby
step will happen
possibly
if yeah the black white rook is going to
give some annoying checks to the black
king that's
that's the problem right now
how is prague going to win this one if
prague tries to go
if he tries to sprint forward and try to
go for a queen if the black f-pawn
pushes down one square away from
promotion the white king is going to
come back and kind of track it
so the black king running back to safety
kaia you're right the black king was
just a bit too
scared of the open there yeah
is this a game where we have to keep
track of uh last pawn to move last piece
to be captured or is that not an issue
yet not yet so the last pawn move was on
let me check
move 50. so we've made six moves only
without a pawn move or without a capture
there is a 50 move rule but
long long way yet it does feel like
pragnanda at some point maybe now can
start pushing his other two pawns black
has two pawns in reserve
and look at the bar after ding moves his
king yeah i think the white king was
quite good there because it was kind of
blocking the black king from ever coming
forward stopping the black pawns from
moving okay here they come here he comes
and uh i agree with you there david that
white king should not have moved it
should have been the white rook that was
doing the heavy lifting and
okay i mean is there a
the white king now has to step forward
right possibly uh black's king actually
can kind of use its own pawns as shelter
the black king might come around the h
uh h file it might come
around the other way while the white
rook okay here it goes first but it's
going to hide behind its own pawns
and here we go prague is going to hide
his king
surely on the g5 square yes opposite the
white king i know it comes to the center
oh that's so clever because now we have
to show this trick i thought this root
look at ding shaking his head uh i
thought this route was just blocked off
the black king coming in now to win this
white pawn i thought it was impossible
because white's root can go and win the
black born but prague has spotted that
he can skewer now the king to the white
rook and he wins the white rook and
prague is going to take this game if
white's rook cannot go and grab this
pawn there's nothing you can do the
black king is just coming in
even if you cut it off even if you cut
off the king's advance then now the
black pawn is just going to step forward
and protect its body here and once this
pawn is protected the black rook is free
prague perfect technique he's going to
win now wow making a comeback in the
match after losing the first game
how impressive by the 16 year old the
bar now saying seven advantage and it
looks like dinger's resigned
it's over and now heidi maybe it's
possible to read ding's body language
yeah yeah he does not seem too happy
right now and pray the number you could
see he had like this
sigh it looked like he was he was very
happy about this yeah he has made a
comeback the 16 year old they are now
tied after two games dingli ren and
pragnanda both of them winning with the
black pieces and uh what a performance
prize prague in this game both of the
players still sitting by the computers
looking
over this
and the question is where is that big
moment when prague did get the win
you needed let's take a look at it david
yeah